[Music]
hey you guys
look at tom with his with his boob
what did what did you call those they're
[Laughter]
yeah and he can also see you through
youtube
even though we recorded this like a long
time ago i can see how big your boobs
are
because yeah so he's so not only can he
see you
like through the tv or through your
laptop he's also like a time lord
yeah across time and space
and your boobs and if they were c-cups
to me they're double e's
[ __ ] you [ __ ] responded don't worry
about it you're not a boob appreciator
we saw this movie about this uh skull
skull the skull this girl
it had uh what's his name peter cushing
peter cushing and his skinny
and christopher lee he's always skinny
asian i came to the conclusion that
uh peter cushing got uh better looking
the older he got
i think so too he's definitely one of
those dudes that i thought i mean
christopher lee did as well
yeah like it helps if you're kind of
like gaunt and cadaverous
and british and sort of classy yeah he
got skinnier as he got older
and i don't know if he was losing wisdom
teeth or what because he's starting to
get more
sunken in he's not that old in this one
he still looks cool you can recognize
him
but he doesn't look like you know he
doesn't look like 1977 you know general
tarkin or anything you know
but if i can he eventually gets that
skinny
yeah they said that he got even skinnier
after his wife died
yeah because he was really yeah he was
like real he wasn't eating much and
everything like that
he said he was just waiting around to
die he didn't give a [ __ ] yeah which i
said that's like a
that's sad i really like that though but
yeah you know he achieved all he was
going to achieve he's just making movies
you know
paycheck and he's like you know [ __ ] it
i'm out of here yeah
yeah but we came across this movie this
was actually made in 1965
and this was only the second movie made
by
amicus productions oh hammer's rival i
guess they weren't really
rivals because they used a lot of the
same actors and stuff it's just
like another one yeah i feel well amicus
they kind of i mean obviously hammer
gets
you know known for making sort of more
gothic stuff uh you know vampires
werewolves [ __ ] like that
whereas amicus was more known for their
uh anthology movies or
portmanteau if you're uh british they
called them
which were several stories and they were
usually set in the modern day
but they made a few movies that were
just like one story as well uh which the
skull
is i feel this is kind of like a little
bit of a forgotten one
hammer x movies actually looked better
they were more colorful you could tell
they were more expensive
yeah and they they showcased boobs a lot
more
it's true the amicus ones they might
have one girl who's boobalicious and
they'll [ __ ] put her in an outfit
that's like
you know yeah we see what you're talking
about we know what you're trying to show
us
but the abacus will just show you one
girl like that
all right the hammer would have like
four or five of them and they'd all be
like hanging out
yeah it was a boob fest like let me bend
over and get it yeah yeah yeah
any opportunity to do a down blouse hell
yeah
and they were all beautiful you know
this was this is 60s and 70s you know
what i mean
show business was still glamorous and
uh england or europe in general
they they kind of glorified feminine
beauty
you know they just the best looking
women from england or germany or italy
the italians did the same thing the
italians were even more egregious
all right they were just straight up
nudes everywhere you know
but uh the british had a nice
uh uh mixture you know what i mean where
yeah they were good-looking girls the
[ __ ] great costumes
really good sets and they show you some
cleavage but they did
sometimes it was nudity but it wasn't
gratuitous you know what i mean or
let's say it wasn't at the italian level
it was longer too
the italian level that's just like here
it is here it is
yeah there's like [ __ ] you know you like
that i want to show you some more of
that
you're jiggling around yeah yeah yeah
they knew exactly what they were doing a
good example of a [ __ ] awesome horror
flick
a hammer horror flick would have been uh
the carmilla
yeah that's a good one lesbian vampires
you can't [ __ ] beat that
well i mean they made i feel like there
was a lot of movies that came out
they're lesbian vampires because that
one was like cha-ching it was like
lesbian vampires
that's all i need to hear just a lot
lots of push-up bras
lots of women making out
dad sees it happen he's like that's not
happening is it or
is this are they a couple that's not
acceptable i mean he's thinking that but
they didn't say it
[Laughter]
remember that when when carmilla comes
down with the with a girl and her and
her dad is like [ __ ] is this all about
yeah yeah like i said
what's she doing well they let me watch
it yeah but yeah so
so amicus i guess i don't know if they
had made like some films
beforehand that weren't horror movies
but their first horror movie
i think was dr terror's house of horrors
which i'm pretty sure that was an
anthology
but then this was their second one now
the thing about the skull
is that it has a lot of the same
uh you know aspects that their
portmanteau films had
in that it's the same director freddie
francis
a lot of the same actors like i said
peter cushing uh christopher lee was in
this one as well
he's billed as like special guest but
he's in it a lot so it's not like a
cameo or anything
and the story was written by uh or it
was based on a story by robert block
who wrote psycho if you didn't know um
and he wrote
so many [ __ ] short stories that
pretty much all of the amicus
movies like the anthology movies all the
stories were written by him
mostly and he also wrote like for
[ __ ] twilight zone and thriller and
like pretty much any horror anthology
show that you could think of so the
story that this was based on
was had the really like workmanlike
title of the skull of the marquis assad
and the story was only six pages long
um so robert block didn't write the
screenplay for this though
um milton stuboski who was one of the
owners of amicus he was like the
the studio head he actually wrote the
screenplay and that's kind of the only i
really did like this movie but i think
that's my only criticism was that you
can definitely tell
that this was a really really short
story that they were kind of like
that they were trying to make um a long
movie
i gotta be honest it to me i thought it
was mediocre
um it was not bad
if you're into this kind of movie you'll
like it
i guess but by modern standards i'd call
this mediocre
um had hammer done it was a
bigger budget it would have been better
i think
it just didn't quite have the eye candy
that it should have had
amicus so far from what i'm seeing
amicus
is is a good company it
wasn't quite up to amber's quality level
yeah
this one it kind of had they almost did
like an homage to hammer at the
beginning because they show
the original dude that goes and steals
the marquis de sade's skull
like you do some grave robber action and
that supposedly happens in 1810 or
whenever the [ __ ] that happens
and he takes it back and tries to boil
the flesh off it and that's when you get
kind of the only half naked woman
because she's like in the tub when she
gets there although you don't see your
boobs or anything you just kind of hear
from the back and she's like oh
yeah naughty um but yeah so it's that
kind of thing and then
something bad happens to him that you
presume the skull had something to do
with
and then they jump ahead to present day
which would be 1965.
and then you have peter cushing and
christopher lee
who are kind of like their friends
colleagues kind of like they know each
other and they're both
collectors of a cult uh paraphernalia
yeah and so they're at an auction
and christopher lee ends up like buying
these weird little statues or whatever
and then so what ends up happening
though is that peter cushing
he has this uh dude that brings him
stuff who's kind of shifty and his name
is marco
and he brings him this book which is
about the marquis de sade and it's
supposedly bound in human skin
um even though it just looks like
regular ass it looks like a regular ass
book but whatever
and then they then they kind of give you
a backstory of marquis de sade in this
uh movie you're led to believe or you're
led to
um what's the word that i'm looking for
you're they're they're positing that
marquis assad was essentially like a
wizard or like a warlock
like that he was a satanist yeah and
that he could had occult powers
and that i don't think that they were
saying that it was him but i think they
mentioned in there that he was
kind of possessed by a demon that and
the demon was still hanging around in
his skull and could make you do [ __ ]
like it can control your mind
essentially kind of possess you
yeah yeah it's kind of a
i guess it's an okay idea i just think
that look it's 1964.
that's when they're making this movie
it's a little conservative even for 64.
there's some other stuff from the same
era that
hammer came out with that is a lot i get
i think
more interesting and kind of have a
sexier element and
a little bit more visual it lacks a lot
of visual
impact it didn't really have
that giallo kind of backlight coloring
that you
had a little bit of that but not much
and that didn't quite have enough women
in it
it was there was a lot of men in in the
movie it needed more female
yeah it was a sausage fest yeah it
needed female character
more female characters even if they were
just eye candy
and and and hammer did that it was just
to keep to keep the male audience more
interested in what was going on
and most of the male audience at the
time it would have been young men
yeah so women didn't watch these kind of
movies really i don't think i mean they
had some but
i think the main market was young man um
it ended up coming off feeling like uh
one of those vincent price edgar allan
poe movies not quite as zany
it was a more serious but it was like
mediocre it was in the middle of
everything they could have intensified
some aspect of it either intensify the
horror or
intensify the sexuality or intensify the
visuality of it you know the visuals
with the colors
it was just kind of conservative that's
what it's a good way of
describing it conservative to me
and therefore kind of like it's a movie
that kind of falls
into the background if you're into these
kind of old british horror movies this
would be one that you would want to
watch
after having seen a bunch of other ones
that were good you start running out of
them
yeah this is kind of like second or
third tier yeah like even for amber
because i feel like amicus honestly i
feel like this
movie and i think i kind of implied this
before but i think it would have worked
better
as a short segment in an anthology movie
because like i said you can definitely
tell that this was a short story you can
tell it was the same
writer it was robert block but you can
definitely tell because there's a lot of
stuff in it
that didn't really need to be in there
um
just because they were trying to make it
to feature length yeah and a lot of
stuff
like you said a lot of stuff that didn't
need to be there because it it was kind
of forgettable
yeah you know what i mean there wasn't
there there was only
one scene in it that would to me was
memorable and that was the one
where um uh uh [ __ ] dude's sitting
there and the skull
comes out of the peter cushing
and the skull comes out of the car it's
a dresser or something or comes off the
shelf
and it sits down on that uh it's a
little table
yeah on the table skull moves around by
itself like gold moves by itself
yeah and that's really the only thing
that i only think that was visually
memorable
now i will say the cinematography for
this was actually pretty cool i liked
the inside
of um cr of uh you know of peter
cushing's
apartment like his house like i loved
that hallway like with the purple and
the black and it's like that was super
cool yeah the settings were good
and his study was really cool and even
like marco the traitor like his
apartment building is actually really
cool with all the stained glass and
everything like him falling through the
stained glass
when he would walk around the paintings
that would turn towards him and certain
there was poltergeist activity that was
pretty yeah i liked that bit too
it was pretty effective like yeah and i
like that that wasn't really brought up
like once
because what ends up happening is that
him and christopher lee like
christopher lee had had the skull but it
was stolen from him
and so peter cushing kind of wanted to
get his hands on it after he had the
book and now he's all interested
and christopher lee was like man you
don't want that [ __ ] it like it can
control your mind it'll like make you
kill people and whatnot
and um you know he's like i was able to
resist it but it was really hard
but of course peter cushing still wants
that [ __ ] anyway and
indeed it does kind of start to like
control his mind and i think
that part of the movie like or
especially near the end where the skull
starts kind of floating around on its
own was like really
cool that was like really well done and
it was like really creepy and then when
he was like walking through the
apartment and like i said sometimes like
the paintings in the background would
like tilt
yeah and like the mirrors would kind of
go weird and stuff yes i will say too
that right when the um right when the
skull first started to
like you know do its kind of like effect
on him or whatever
there was this really great surreal
scene where he gets
like two guys show up at his door and
say that they're cops and they're like
hey you're under arrest for murder or
whatever
and he doesn't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about because he was
just sitting there reading mine in his
own beeswax and like so he goes to this
place and it's and it goes like all
[ __ ] franz kafka like he goes into
this room and it's all blue
and there's nothing in there except you
know
the judge's bench and the judge sitting
on it and then they like
they hold a gun to the back of his head
and make him play russian roulette
and then it so it keeps clicking and
then like he runs into another room and
it's all red
so it's like this really weird
surrealist
kind of [ __ ] in there which i actually
kind of liked that that they put that in
there
yeah too even though it was just kind of
trying to show that his mind was
fracturing because of the skull's
influence you know
yeah those interior shots would a lot
would have looked a lot better had the
italians shot them though
true although like i said there were a
couple of touches where
they tried they would where they tried
like it'd be like a really saturated
like green
light or something like that well the
british knew about it i mean they were
doing it they did it in that movie cycle
mania
yeah remember that they kind of had that
giallo color effects and that you know
hammer did it too
yeah it just they were good interior
shots it's just they didn't really like
pop yeah they should have it's almost
kind of like it was a workmansh
it was just a workman like job hey let's
let's get this thing shot and get it
over with it
it probably didn't take long to make
this um it's
and you know the budget is going to be
low
so yeah i don't think they had as much
money to work yeah
it's not like you know you so maybe i'm
a little harsh on it but the thing is
that once you make these movies they're
around for a long time might as well
just throw the extra money in there man
[ __ ] learn how to [ __ ]
throw some colored lights on some stuff
spice it up make it a little more visual
and i think maybe the movie would have
been i think like you said the edit is a
little funny too because they've
stretched it out
yeah it seems like it would have worked
better as like a short
inside like a larger because it reminded
for some reason it's really weird that
robert block
wrote this story like about a skull
marquis de sade skull that for some
reason can control your mind and make
you kill people because he's a wizard or
a warlock or whatever
i'm pretty sure if i'm not remembering
this right
but i think robert block also wrote a
short story that i read a long time ago
about jack the ripper's knife and if you
found jack the ripper's knife that would
also make you kill people yeah i mean
i'm pretty sure
so so that was maybe one of robert
block's things where it's just like an
object that was owned by like an evil
person like
you know if you pick it up it's going to
make you do the same [ __ ] as that person
had hammered done this there had been a
lot of more women in it
and then one of the hottest woman there
would have been possessed by marquis de
sade
and then she would have done some like
lesbian bondage
yeah yeah this was like very did some
[ __ ] it was very unsexual about
the marquis de sade you've got the
makita side and there's no [ __ ]
bondage there's no lesbian bondage
they kind of didn't talk about because
they do like i said when peter cushing
first gets the book about marquis de
sade and he doesn't really know that
much about him
so they do kind of this thing where he's
like talking about his history
but the whole thing about it is that
they just said that he's something about
oh cruelty and everything like that like
he was an evil
like black he was into black magic or
whatever but they don't say anything
about the sadomasochism or like him
being a pervert or anything like that
and just think of how that would have
played differently
and now when you said that there's like
no women the only women that are in this
movie
are the chicken the bathtub at the
beginning like in the 1810 portion of
the movie
and uh yeah and she's like naked but she
don't get to see anything
and peter cushing's wife who's only in
like two scenes
yeah and she's only in there she's like
not even a character hardly she's only
in there like to be menaced at the end
or you know so like peter cushing is
like oh my god i'm going to kill my wife
because the skull told me to
and that's so you get that scene at the
end which is a good scene but
i think it would have been more
effective if they had built her
character up more
have you never read any of market
assad's books or know who that guy was
you wouldn't know
what the marquis de sade was on the
basis of this movie you wouldn't know
what
you would say well who's that is he like
anton levay
because he might have gone i kind of
feel like they were trying to make it
more like anton levine because this was
mostly just like black magic
right yeah there wasn't any sex or there
wasn't any sexual element to it
no so and in a way that they might have
been kind of like
a trolling or fishing in a way they're
trying to get people to come in
on the back of [ __ ] you know on the
back of
[ __ ] this side's notoriety
with the promises of maybe seeing some
bdsm yeah
that maybe somebody's gonna get away
yeah we're gonna get you gonna see some
bdsm i'm gonna get tired now we see some
suspension or some [ __ ] like that you
know what i mean
and no none of that happens but they
should have
had had had hammer done this it would
have
well yeah they would have gotten away
with everything they could have gotten
in 1965.
the ghost of assad would have gone into
the hottest chick there
and abused the other women and then
she'd have been doing all kind of like
wanting [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
she'd have been doing [ __ ] to herself in
front of the mirror because that's what
assad would have done if he'd got inside
a woman he'd done all kinds of weird
[ __ ]
he was trisexual he just tried
everything
[Laughter]
he'd have gone into men too though yeah
like you said you want to try everything
yeah he's trying everything so
essentially this is almost kind of like
like i mentioned that i'm pretty sure
that that story was written by robert
block and i think it was just called the
knife and it was about jack the ripper's
knife and how it made you you find it
somebody finds it like in a gutter or
something and then they start stabbing
people
and this was kind of like that it's like
the marquis de sade skull
all he wanted you to do he was
controlling your mind and he would like
the skull would like woo out of the
[ __ ] you know out of the cabinet or
whatever and then it would light the
black candles
and then it would make you go out and
kill people and you didn't remember
and i don't know necessarily why the
people that got killed like
needed to be killed like i think they
were just like random
like hey let's want just start killing
people you know just for the [ __ ]
shits and giggles maybe i don't know i
think this is the second or third amicus
movie i've seen
and this is the weakest one out of the
three today yeah i mean i can see why
like it's like i said you know and i i
don't mean to be too harsh
on it because it's still like a good
movie it's a good looking movie peter
cushing
is always amazing christopher lee is
always amazing it's a cool idea like i
like some of the scenes and i like
the [ __ ] with the skull and everything i
just like you said i feel like they
could have done more with that concept
yeah it's it it's it felt dated to me
this
felt like uh like an old classic horror
movie like
old dracula or old uh uh frankenstein
you know what
what's uh the universal monsters almost
like some from old universal
yeah i see what you're saying you know
i'm talking about didn't feel like 1964.
1964 could be a lot wilder than this
and they played it safe it was
conservative
yeah i would you know or just real low
budget so they just had to do with what
they could what could they could afford
to do
yeah i mean this was only their second
horror movie though well
amex is saying for amicus yeah i mean
they had made like i said they'd made dr
tara's house of horrors which i think
i've seen but i don't really remember
much about it
but this was their second one and like
you could really tell they were trying
to do like something cool with it
um you know with this kind of lurid
premise
but it doesn't really live up to the
lordness of that premise as far as these
british flicks go
from what i've seen so far i haven't
seen them all jenny's really an expert
on it
when it comes to the 1960s you want to
see hammer
when it comes to the 1970s you want to
see those sinbad movies and like you
know
uh land the time forgotten people at
time forgot what what company did those
do you remember
i don't really remember actually yeah
they were almost like star wars before
star wars
some of the same studios and people that
worked on those worked on star wars a
few years later
but um yeah so far i'd say hammer
hammer yeah and like i said there's were
you know they were more expensive but
honestly i like a lot of amicus's um
uh you know anthology movie i gotta see
more of it i like a lot of their
anthology movies
and like i said i like that they were
kind of doing something a little bit
different they weren't like
stepping on hammer's dick um you know
it's like oh we're gonna do gothic
horror too but
we don't have as much money they just
wanted to do more modern pieces
and more uh you know and doing short
stories
mostly what they did and like i said i
feel like this
this movie would have been a lot better
if this story had just been one
part of like an anthology like like they
would usually do
had they just changed it from market
assad to somebody else the story would
have made a little bit more sense to me
maybe
yeah you could have just said it was
like some black magician like from back
then it was [ __ ] tokamata
you know yeah yeah yeah that would have
been even better
him out of skull he had a demon in him
yeah you know he was out killing people
i mean it could have worked
it could have worked with anybody
honestly it should have they should have
just had somebody that was a black
magician
or you know that was into black magic or
was just like a murderer
yeah you know what i mean if you're
going to do marquis de sade that brings
people have a certain perception yeah
you're going to see what you're going to
see with that
and you don't really see it so like i
said it's just very strangely non-sexual
for being about right
like controlling people's behavior
you were going to see some perverted
[ __ ] if the side wasn't was it was there
yeah and it's like i realized they
couldn't show a lot of that stuff in the
in
the movies in 1960s but they could have
like i said they could have implied it
well
64 you could get away with a lot of [ __ ]
i mean [ __ ]
da'sod was a power top power bottom
the power traitor uh he would just you
know what i mean do
do all kinds of weird [ __ ] to people you
know and then write about all kinds
i don't know how much of the stuff he
actually did what he just you know a lot
of like he'd probably just imagine
imagine a lot of that [ __ ] he was like
yeah he was like fan favorite you get
thrown in prison doing this [ __ ]
well he did but he did he was drugging
people
well yeah yeah which even back then was
pretty illegal
hookers go to jail for that
so like i said that's that's that's
something anyway that was actually
illegal
yeah although they said that i might
have been blown out of proportion too it
was something kind of like fla
spanish fly that he gave yeah or so you
thought of some kind of aphrodisiac they
complained about it
i don't know if it was hysteria or what
because they didn't have the technology
for viagra yeah yeah yeah
it was probably just rolled up damn
chili powder
they didn't know much back then you know
what i mean there's like one stomach
ache and they wouldn't [ __ ] see he
gave us poison
yeah he poisoned me yeah chili powder
well you know i don't want to be
drinking that either it's like hey this
will spice up our lovely yeah
oh man now i have [ __ ] now i really
don't feel like having sex because now i
have from the far away land of mexico
yeah that's exotic [ __ ] probably nothing
more than habanero
probably yeah well because like i said
it's it's very like magical thinking
which is
yeah it's you know like does like it's
like if something is hot
then it's supposed to make you like all
hot and like [ __ ] aroused and
everything then they run to the run to
the police he tried to poison us and
then they got [ __ ] assad in there
doing time and the best steal for
[ __ ] giving some chicks habanero
pepper
but that was the thinking of the time
they were they they wrote great
literature they
but they they were smart but they made a
lot of mistakes but they pooped in bowls
but they they sat in [ __ ] thoughts
[Laughter]
their thinking wasn't modern you would
save that for later it wasn't very sound
they were superstitious
yeah and like i said if something i mean
any food or anything like that that
you know was hot or was slimy or
whatever
that was that's poison if it well no if
you ate it that was supposed to have the
same effect like on a human
yeah but they would also think that that
would be like poisoning somebody yeah
yeah you know
you roofied them yeah habanero
yeah yeah now she's trying to [ __ ]
everything
she can't control herself she's out of
control
she's not they're trying to help someone
what did you do to my daughter
once and harlot yeah yes i i can't take
it
i kind of feel like that's probably what
happened like a lot of
women that did stuff like that they were
just kind of like that's why they said
they were all like possessed by devils
and stuff because that was the only way
they could get out of [ __ ] and like not
get in trouble
and then they they could just run around
and be like a total [ __ ] and like
like be like hey it's not i'm not
responsible for that [ __ ] i
i didn't do it he gave me some money he
gave me some [ __ ]
and then i just started running around
like humping everybody yeah you know
what i mean and then i was like
this i was thinking it was a damage it
worked
i'll write that [ __ ] down let me use
that again
habanero works
[Laughter]
makes chicks hump everything inside yeah
i like it yeah but yeah so
uh so this movie is on we watched on
amazon
gaming is on prime it's free on there i
think it's also on shutter it was added
not too long because i feel like this is
kind of like
not a forgotten necessarily but it's
kind of an amicus movie that not a lot
of people talk about
um and you know watching it like i said
it's a good movie i enjoyed it
i liked i liked the shots like that were
like skull cam
like through the eyes of the skull like
they were watching i thought that was
kind of cool
uh so there's kind of there's a lot of
good [ __ ] in it but it's not
really one of their best ones my verdict
is that it's a good movie
on its own uh it's not one of the first
ones you want to see if you're
if you want to see these little clip
classic british horror flicks go see all
the hammer stuff first
in the amicus if you're going to watch
the amicus ones i would recommend the
you know the anthologies first and then
kind of go back and see these
this is when you you you see something
like this after you've got a taste for
the genre and you've
you've seen all the other ones and
you're working your way down yeah yeah
it's kind of like when you're getting to
like the bottom when you become an
expert
yeah i hadn't seen it this was the first
time i actually thought all right
so that'll do it for this matinee
we'll see you guys later bye